voilà un sujet très intéressant parce
que et c'est justement ce que je voulais
vous dire aujourd'hui quand ciani a pour
slogan innovation for everyone c'est de
l'innovation écrit de la même manière
c'est pas très compliqué fort pourra pas
reprendre les cours d'anglais
aujourd'hui everyone tout le monde de
l'innovation pour tout le monde alors
bien souvent on a entendu ça en disant
que xiaot me rendais l'innovation
accessible à tout le monde on le prend
donc effectivement en disant que toute
l'innovation qui coûte aujourd'hui
relativement cher et bien on peut la
trouver à des tarifs cassés à des tarifs
au plus bas grâce à chaud me d'où l'idée
de l'innovation for everyone ça c'est
vrai mais on peut leur en offre donc
parce que quand je vois une fois de plus
mon petit papier for everyone everyone
everyone everyone pour tout le monde et
qui dit tout le monde c'est
effectivement pour les gens qui ne
veulent pas mettre beaucoup d'argent
dans un smartphone ni mais également
pour les personnes qui veulent mettre un
gros budget dans leurs smartphones
du coup xiaomi peut potentiellement
toucher tout le monde everyone en
délaissant personnes donc quand j'ai
omis à rien et cross mark von a
quasiment 1000 euros sur son très haut
de gamme
eh bien ça me surprend pas ça va prendre
beaucoup moins parce qu'on se dit ok ok
au qui attendait qu'est ce qui se passe
si on me c'est la marque qui propose des
smartphones avec les meilleurs spec les
meilleures innovations à des prix cassés
avec des marges extrêmement minime et
des tarifs touba tout bâton batum à
touba pourquoi est ce qu'aujourd'hui
chez audi avec des smartphones qui
coûtent respectivement sur le 1010 7 199
90 salah c'est écrit là là c'est très
très mal écrit c'est monsieur rocchi a
écrit et pour le midi ce pro 1000 euros
9 199 90
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
que je suis en vie c'est une marque une
fois de plus qu'ils proposent de
l'innovation forêt peu douanes puisque
vous le dira pas ce que j'ai vu je suis
allé chez eux dans leur salle de réunion
à boulogne billancourt
c'est écrit en gros au fond de la salle
innovation for everyone innovation for
everyone
on retrouve là alors je dois continuer
la visite
il cherche donc à toucher beaucoup plus
de bons skis vachement intéressant c'est
que chez au mythe arrivée en france
alors je vous parle que de la force
aujourd'hui si on me a river aller en
europe mai 2010 8 mai 2018 déjà ça passe
à une vitesse incroyable
ça fera quasiment deux ans en commençant
par l'entrée de gamme qui fait toujours
leur force c'est ce qui a fait leur
force notamment sur l'importation des
smartphones depuis la chine
aujourd'hui il cherche à élargir leur
gamme à être présent partout bien
évidemment ils vont rester prononce sur
leur coeur de cible historique le
smartphone très intéressante de super
spec pas très cher mais si vous voulez
plus de spec aller plus loin et bien
vous montez sont des tarifs beaucoup
plus haut et c'est vachement intéressant
parce que là je parle tous tarifs
je n'ai pas encore pas de smartphone les
nanas ont sorti le mil neuf le mil neuf
si vous cherchiez la config 6.64 sur le
stockage nous étions à 449 euros et la
version jusqu'à 128 g de stockage vous
étiez à 499 euros
aujourd'hui porté sur 1 me disent sur
une version 8 plus de 156 g toujours pas
parlé du produit je vous en présente
quelques instants vous rajouter 300
euros et vous arrivez sur le prix du
smartphone
donc ça veut dire que derrière schumi a
fait un vrai boulot sur l'innovation sur
de la recherche développement pour aller
plus haut en termes de gammes proposées
toujours plus plus de spec
c'est justement ça qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui alors chien vous le dire
c'est une situation extrêmement
particulière à malemort scanner
lancement le show me et bien je suis
dans le coin je suis présent et puis je
suis là pour vous présenter les produits
je vous emmène avec moi j'aurai toujours
en plus dans les coulisses découvrir ce
qui se passe parler avec des
journalistes avec d'autres potes
influence or pour voir un peu comment se
passe un peu tout ça aujourd'hui c'est
pas possible à cause du corona des
russes
on reste à la maison le jour c'est sorti
une vidéo vous lisant de m'envoyer vos
vidéos vos extraits de vous chez vous
pour vous est confiné que justement on
retient aujourd'hui avec une vidéo qui
met à envoyer et si vous voulez vous
m'envoyez la vôtre pour dire comment ça
se passe chez vous pour le couronner les
russes vous pouvez y aller vous avez
l'e-mail qui s'affiche l' amour
@ monsieur grand point fr salue monsieur
russell the one hand ça moineau pêche
laurent jeanne belgique de liège pendant
un petit confinement bas on vous sur le
pc etc alors regarde aussi des vidéos de
monsieur greu évidemment parce que sinon
c'est pas cool et bien des fonds prend
l'air on va se balader on va courir faut
bien réussi un petit peu ça irait plus
bas voilà on les fait c'est pas trop
avoir des contacts c'est assez difficile
mais bon on perd avec 1
faut ce qu'il faut et on espère que dans
quelques semaines dont pourra ressortir
merci à toi de m'avoir envoyé cette
vidéo n'oubliez pas de m'envoyer la
vôtre si vous souhaitez partager votre
quotidien savoir comment ça se passe et
vous savez grand plaisir partageons de
l'amour pendant cette période un peu
compliquée période compliquée pour les
marques également chez aubry n'a pas pu
être présent comme il aurait dû le faire
il aurait dû lancer leurs seins me dise
series lors du mwc à barcelone qui a été
annulé à cause du corona des russes
alors qu'on n'avait pas encore la crise
qu'on a aujourd'hui en europe
néanmoins il se rattrape ils viennent de
présenter plein de smartphones et
justement parmi ces smartphones à 2
principalement d'eau je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui et je vous parlerai des
autres un peu plus tard australe et est
plus tard le smartphone malheureusement
je n'ai pas pu la voir
il n'a pas pu m envoyer les conditions
sont un peu particulières qu'il aurait
bientôt donc on en reparlera mais en
tout cas la fiche technique
croyez-moi elle fait vraiment mal et on
va pas jouer les trois smartphones et
principalement de deux le me dise le
1010 pro et elles me disent light b17 on
en parlera un peu plus tard mais pour
l'instant vraiment se concentrer sur le
midi et les milices pro
que vous soyez sur le midi où sont les
milices pro vous avez le même design
vous avez un grand écran avec un écran
poinçonnet un petit point sont en façade
pour venir à passer la caméra vous avez
des smartphones qui font le même poids 2
108 g
corning gorilla glass 5 à l'avant et à
l'arrière ce le même form factor c'est
le même smartphone sauf que dans le
modèle pro bien vous en douterez vous en
avez un petit peu plus l'écran c'est la
même chose vous avez un écran amoled 2 6
7 pouces avec un réseau de 19 points 5/9
un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 us pour aller
plus loin pour la gamer alors je sais
beaucoup de smartphones très haut de
gamme sont 120 hertz en ce début d'année
2020 chez tommy a fait le choix de
rester sur du 90 heures ce qui fera
parfaitement l'affairé je ne suis pas
sûr contre le 90e et le sens wallers
les et tout le monde voit la différence
en tout cas ça vaudra plus de fluidité
notamment qu'on les gamers et même vous
lorsque vous allez venir naviguer
vous allez venir scrollé un écran
truecolor qui occupent 92 18 4% de la
face avant
mais évidemment il est h dr death plus
nous annonce une luminosité allant
jusqu'à 800 dit 100% dci p3 un belle
taille inférieure à
et bien évidemment certifié lutter
contre la lumière bleue le duo est
également le même entre le midi et deux
les dix pros qu'on a des haut parleurs
stéréo un sont certifiés highways haute
résolution et au niveau du bluetooth
vous avez un codec lhd c&a ptx dans les
deux cas vous avez un snapdragon 865
c'est le dernier soc de qualcomm
vous avez dans les deux cas 8 gigas de
ram en lp ddr 500 midi sous une version
128 go de stockage et 256 go de stockage
en usb 3.0 tandis que sur le me disent
pro vous avez uniquement une version en
256 cas du stockage bien évidemment
toujours en usb 3.0 tout en mettra
d'avoir une meilleure lecture et
écriture ça ira plus vite en
refroidissement graphène en huit couches
donc un smartphone qui ne va pas
chauffer on a besoin de refroidissement
parce que dans les deux cas oui vous
avez un smartphone 5 g avec le modèle x
55 de qualcomm
vous avez une différence au niveau de la
batterie elle est pas énorme mais elle
est là sans le midi vous avez une
batterie de 4780 milliampères heures
tandis que son milices pro vous avez des
batteries de 4500 brillante erreur une
batterie un petit peu moindre se joue à
pas grand chose mais pourquoi la
différence est bien là sur le me disent
que ce soit de la recharge filaire ou la
recharge sans fil vous avez de la
recharge 30 watts avec le chargeur de 30
watts inclus dans la boîte tandis que
sur le milices pro et c'est assez
intéressant vous avez de la recharge
filaire 50 watts et de la recharge sans
fil 30 watts mais ce qui est surprenant
c'est que vous avez un chargeur 60 100
watts qui inclus dans la boîte
dans les deux cas vous avez la recharge
d'un verset 5 watts c'est à dire que
votre smartphone va pouvoir recharger
par d'autres smartphones des écouteurs
ou peu importe en 5 watts et une des
parties qui nous intéresse le plus c'est
la photo vous avez le même capteur de 5
mégapixels dans un modèle et dans
l'autre c'est le capteur principal qui
ouvre à f 1.69 permettra de regrouper
cas pixels en un pour capter plus de
luminosité avec un plus grand capteur et
une stabilisation optique tandis que la
différence va commencer à arriver après
alors je vous donne pour le midi et les
explique après pour le midi ce procès va
devenir extrêmement intéressant sur le
me disent vous avez un ultra grand pan
de 13 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.4 avec
un champ de vision de 123 degrés et vous
avez deux caméra de 2 mégapixels qui
toutes les deux à f 2.4 la première
c'est pour de la macro la deuxième c'est
pour le feu d'arrière plan c'est pour
les faibles ok bon la macro je suis pas
persuadé que ce soit exceptionnel j'ai
déjà testé je suis pas hyper emballé la
2 mégapixels pour le flou d'arrière-plan
ça fait le taf
mais là où ça devient extrêmement
intéressant ce sont les modèles
professionnels qui va vraiment les bons
coups plus loin en photo et qui pour le
coup mérite vraiment son appellation
professionnelle parce que vous avez un
capteur ultra grand-angle de 20 méga
pixels avec une ouverture de f/2 points
6 avec un champ de vision de 117 degré
plutôt bien mais là où c'est à dire
vraiment vraiment bien c'est que vous
avez une caméra de 12 mégapixels qui va
être là pour le mode portrait pour la
profondeur de champ mais surtout c'est
un tel objectif avec un zoom optique x 2
elle ouvre à f 2.4 et en plus de ça vous
avez notre caméra un capteur de 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0 qui va
aussi travailler pour la profondeur mais
surtout avec 15 ou l'hybride x 10 et un
zoom numérique x 50 et celle là a
également une stabilisation optique
alors ça j'ai vraiment hâte de tester
voir de quelle manière je suis remis à
travailler en terme de hardware mais
également en termes de software et est
ce que la solution est vraiment
performante ou pas dans les deux cas
vous avez caméra de cette fille de 20
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.3 dans les
deux cas bouffard de la vidéo jusqu'en
licka à 30 images par seconde
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit extrêmement
intéressant de monter en lui cas jusqu'à
30 images par seconde
mais si vous voulez faire vous pouvez
faire que ce soit le met 10 ou milices
pro vous avez bien évidemment du lfc de
l'infrarouge du wifi 6 sur le 1010 vous
avez la couleur qu'ils appellent le gris
crépuscule et le verre corey tandis que
les milices pro vous retrouver en blanc
alpin et en gris solstice je sais pas
qui sort les dénominations des couleurs
mais c'est toujours très très beau et
très harmonieux et six espaces quand
vous intéresse que ce soit l'un ou
l'autre vous avez dans les deux cas les
mitrons wireless de offert coûte quand
même 99 euros 90 le musicien qu'on n'en
parlera plus tard mais ce cas vous
donnez le tarif à savoir que c'est un
smartphone à 5 g qui sera disponible en
mai au tarif de 399 euros 90 donc vous
allez avoir un smartphone 5 g à moins de
400 euros
et ça c'est vraiment bien quelles sont
donc les points à obtenir sur ses
smartphones me dise milices pro c'est
bien évidemment le fait que shiomi n'ai
fait aucun compromis au risque de se
voir reprocher par sa communauté
d'afficher des tarifs beaucoup trop
élevé parce que oui bien évidemment les
fans de la première heure diront que
xiaomi a vraiment augmenté ses tarifs
cherche peut-être à gagner plus d'argent
j'imagine carrière beaucoup de critiques
moi ce que je retiens est ce que je vois
derrière ça c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure
innovation for everyone je pourrais
presque même prendre le pari qu'en 2021
si on arrive à proposer un smartphone à
plus de 1000 euros ces smartphones on en
reparlera très très très très très très
très prochainement puisque j'ai bientôt
les tester vous invite donc à vous
abonner dès maintenant ce n'est pas déjà
le cas et n'oubliez pas une vraie chaîne
frère et oued vous nous dire ce que vous
en pensez
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
que ce slogan là il vaut pour tout le
monde
for everyone pour les personnes qui
veulent pas mettre beaucoup d'argent
mais aussi pour ceux qui veulent mettre
beaucoup d'argent c'est parce que vous
en pensez en bas comment vous trouvez
sur le papier ses smartphones
on en reparlera prochainement sur le
test a vous de me dire comment vous les
trouvez vous en bas en commentaire sur
ce embrasse vous envoie beaucoup d'amour
envoyez moi vos vidéos de confinement et
puis des bisous et à demain
ciao
[Musique]
en matchs éliminatoires
m
le texte
quand on peut